I saw this with Ross Tucker that Tom
Brady voluntarily makes about half what
he should yet the Patriots are making
him earn an extra five million dollars
how is that not insulting Ross Tucker
joins us on loan from NBC Sports Network
and the Ross Tucker football podcast and
he joins us now
good morning Ross oh yeah good he
explained this to me what the Patriots
are doing to Tom Brady I have no idea I
was tweeting about that this morning how
is that not insulting I mean the guys
schedule to make 15 million year the
next two years and that's probably what
half Stan of what he's really worth I
mean he's pretty he's really worth even
more than that but based on the market
right now it's half of what he's really
worth clearly based on you know some of
the rumbles this offseason he kind of
wanted a bump up and so now they're
giving them five million dollars and
incentives and so this is bizarre Dan
now maybe they are not likely to be
earned incentives and it's a salary cap
thing but that's a joke I mean first of
all the guy led the NFL in passing yards
last year and was the MVP so anything
that's not likely to be earned that's
that's hard to accomplish number one and
then number two he's under contract for
next year there are a million different
salary cap mechanisms as you know Dan
that they could do to just give him five
million dollars more I mean if that's
all he's asking for if I was Bob Kraft
and Bill Belichick and all Tom Brady
wanted was 5 million bucks more I would
be so thankful and then just give it to
him this this to me is bizarre I think
there are 43 players who are paid more
than Tom Brady is McLovin did you find
out how many quarterbacks are paid more
than time you know I'll get that in a
sec yeah why why is now Brady has been a
bargain but he's taken less or they
spread it out so they could spend money
elsewhere is that is that been the
common logic here between you know
behind Brady and the Patriots it has
been what's funny about that though Dan
is they're not a team that's typically
butting up against
salary cap and I think they have a
bigger middle-class than most teams you
know they're not going to spend huge
money on guys that they went out and got
Stephon Gilmore where a couple years ago
or a year ago and they spent big money
for him they have more guys making like
between two and five million dollars
that kind of add up than other teams but
yeah I've always thought that was
curious that Brady takes less and it's
like every year it's like okay well
there goes Malcolm Butler
there goes Dion Lewis Oh goodbye Nate's
older my left tackle like I mean at what
point is Brady like wait a minute I am
taking less money and not only are you
not playing Malcom Butler and the Super
Bowl for some reason they give us the
best chance to win the game but you're
also letting my left tackle walk out the
door so now they got Trent Brown at left
tackle who the 49ers didn't even want to
play right tackle and that's the guys
protecting your 41 year old backside
crazy
I took exception or I disagreed it took
exception sounds strong I disagreed with
a tweet you had last night where you
said I swear Baker Mayfield look just
like Drew Brees on his touchdown throw
and it's not just because they're both
6-foot white guys I see more bread I see
more bread far than I do Drew Brees with
Baker Mayfield I can see that I think
personality-wise Baker Mayfield is
definitely more like Brett Favre
definitely but in the pocket I I was
just so struck by how athletic and
active his feet were and how quick he
went through his progressions and turned
his shoulders like Drew Brees does that
even in pregame warmups it's kind of
weird like he'll throw the ball to the
right sideline then he'll quit swivel
his hips in the middle then to the other
side to mentally go through his
progressions and watching Baker Mayfield
at 6 foot and the way he moved around
and manipulated the pocket and went
through his progression so quickly I
just I thought it looked like Drew Brees
I really did now Brees isn't as fast as
Mayfield was on that one
or whatever but in the pocket he's as
close to drew brees as I can remember
seeing what do you expect out of Andrew
Luck and the Colts this season I think
luck is very fortunate in that unlike a
lot of these other guys stand that if
they lost their arm talent or if their
arm wasn't quite as strong they'd be
totally done
Andrew smart enough and knowledgeable
enough from a football standpoint he'll
figure it out like even if even if his
arm is at 85 percent of what it used to
be
he'll still be a good player in the NFL
because he moves around pretty well and
he's that bright I think that division
is totally up for grabs I can see
anything winning it I still though would
probably have the Colts and last I just
don't think they have enough around him
Jacksonville is loaded Houston is one of
the more interesting team that I've seen
in a while where you have like five stud
players all coming off major injuries so
kind of unknown what happens there and I
think Tennessee is under the radar for a
team that won a playoff game on the road
last year and then added some pieces so
I think Luck healthy all season puts the
Colts in the mix but I still don't think
that they're good enough to win that
division talking to Ross Tucker Ross
Tucker football podcast also works with
the NBC Sports Network Westwood One and
Sirius XM the Dallas Cowboys I don't
know what the over/under I think it's
nine and a half but you know I have
concerns I have more concerns with the
Cowboys than I probably thought I was
going to they don't have a big receiver
you do have the line you do have the
running back I don't know about the
defense I'm not sure still about the
play calling situational play calling
with the Cowboys they can be predictable
but your thoughts on what you expect out
of the Cowboys yeah I'm not as high I'm
not very high on the Cowboys either you
look at it Dan and we'll see if they get
our autonomous a lot of people still
think that's going to end up happening
but they've got as bad of a wide
receiving corps as there is in the NFL
they've got probably the worst tight end
group in the NFL I mean Jeff Swain and
Blake Darwin those are the tight ends
and that's a big difference from having
a guy that's reliable like Jason Wynn
and even as good as their offensive line
is I didn't think Connor Williams look
great at left guard last night Lyle
Cowan's really struggled at Lane tackle
a year ago and then they have the
defensive issue so I'm with you I think
actually they're their win total keeps
going down and I still probably hit the
under just because they got a pretty
tough schedule they play the NFC South I
think the Redskins will be better I
think the Giants will definitely be
better and the Eagles are still good so
I mean the Giants feel like another me
I'm sorry the Cowboys feel like another
seven or eight win team to me because I
also didn't think that Prescott looked
real good at the end of last year we'll
see if he can bounce back I think it was
was at Martellus Bennett who has a
podcast where he said that it's Aaron
Rodgers is a better quarterback than Tom
Brady but Brady is easier to play for if
that sounds right McLovin do I have that
right with Bennett I actually don't know
that quote okay that sounds right yes
you think he said it was something like
I said maybe he said Rodgers had a
better arm but Brady throws a more
catchable ball okay it was something of
that ilk though for sure is that true
it's pretty clear though Dan what
Martellus Bennett did not get along with
Aaron Rodgers and that was I was not
that was not a good I don't think he
ever I mean what do you play a couple
games maybe and then he got hurt and
they thought he should come back from
injury and he did I mean that was just a
real real bad situation all around he
did not have a good experience in Green
Bay and vice versa does Aaron Rodgers in
his career as the best quarterback in
the NFL over that period even though Tom
Brady's gonna have all of these Super
Bowls like how does that work that the
guy who it feels like is the general
consensus best quarterback has won Super
Bowl yeah and so I think you're right
then that a lot of people look at it
that way and I think that that's in
large part and and you contributed to
this by the way back in your sports and
I think we're becoming more and more on
social media more and more of a
highlight culture right like so what do
I see all morning is all this all these
highlights of how big and strong Josh
Allen's arm is the Lamar Jackson play
over and over again you know nobody's
really great at what they do by flashes
of brilliance its consistency that makes
people great one of the reasons why I
think people are so high on Aaron
Rodgers is he has consistency and
flashes of brilliance that make us
marvel at some of the throws he makes
that we don't really see that from Brady
but I'm with you in the sense that Aaron
Rodgers not only does the only have one
Super Bowl title then they haven't even
gotten back me Brady has gone to the
Super Bowl what is it eight times in his
17 years where he's actually played or
something which is insane Aaron Rodgers
has been to one so I almost look at it
differently I look at Aaron Rodgers like
he's a play or two away in that Super
Bowl against the Steelers for being Miss
generations Dan Marino you know where he
wins one Super Bowl early wasn't able to
get it done we all marvel at how he can
throw the ball he's awesome we love
watching them but not able to get done
as it and what's even more bizarre to me
than that Dan I was think about this one
time if you go back to like 92 right
when Brett Favre was first starting for
the Packers the Packers have had a top
five quarterback in every year for like
26 years now and they won two Super
Bowls that doesn't seem that good to me
I mean the Ravens have won two Super
Bowls with Trent Dilfer and Joe Flacco
Eli Manning won two Super Bowls and none
of them worked at five but the Packers
for 26 years in a row have had a top
five quarterback and they've won two
Super Bowls to me that's that's
underachieving having a top five
quarterback for 26 consecutive years
more of these opinions Ross Tucker's
football podcast hey have a great
weekend bud we appreciate your time as
always absolutely there
jealous of the meet Friday fellas yeah
thank you that's a Ross Tucker for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]